Everyone in the sleepy mountain town had heard
stories about the abandoned mall, and the
malevolent creature that lurked in the wreckage
there.
There had been enough missing persons cases,
lost children, teenagers sneaking out to explore
and never returning home, urban explorers
who stumbled out of the darkness disheveled
and traumatized, with an eyewitness account
no one wanted to believe.
There wasn't anyone left in the surrounding
area willing to set foot in that cursed place.
But that didn't stop opportunistic out-of-towners
from paying the occasional visit.
Especially if they felt like there was money
to be made in those crumbling corporate walls.
Grant and Jason, the hosts of up-and-coming
investigative reality show "Ghostly Happenings,"
were two such visitors.
When they heard the rumors about an abandoned
mall haunted by some sort of dark presence
blamed for the disappearance of local children,
they packed up their van, picked up their
underpaid cameraman Derek, and headed straight
for the infamous building.
"Are you sure we're allowed to be here?"
Derek asked shakily as he began filming.
"Nope!"
Grant answered cheerfully.
"It's part of the fun," Jason laughed.
"Look man, this place has been left to rot
by the city.
No one cares if we're shooting some footage.
Besides, worry less about the cops and more
about...the ghost of the mall."
Grant grinned.
"OooooOOooOooo."
"Not funny," Derek grumbled.
"Come on, serious faces on!
We're rolling."
Jason nudged his cohost, and the two snapped
into their on-camera personalities.
"Once a bustling center of suburban American
life, this shopping mall has transformed into
a den of terror."
Grant's voice dropped into a lower register,
his expression intense.
"Locals swap stories of something inhuman
that calls this place home.
Something that doesn't take kindly to trespassers,"
Jason added.
"A ghost?
A demon?
Just an urban legend?
That's what we're here to find out."
Grant pulled out an EMF reader, which began
beeping as he turned it on.
"There seems to be a lot of activity in here
already, I'm picking up something."
"Don't know if you folks at home can see this,
but the meter's going crazy!"
Jason exclaimed.
It was a fake meter, of course, one they'd
rigged up to beep and react when Grant pressed
certain hidden buttons.
But the audience didn't need to know that.
They were tuning in for story, for spectacle,
not for the truth.
If they wanted that, they could flip over
to the nature channel and watch some lions
chasing a gazelle.
On this show, they were chasing pure entertainment.
They continued deeper into the building, taking
in the massive, echoey space, the dusty storefronts,
the beams of rotten wood strewn across the
ground, the rats that skittered across the
floor.
It was the perfect creepy atmosphere.
Maybe a little too perfect, a little too creepy.
"What was that?!"
Derek practically jumped out of his skin,
spinning around to look at something behind
him.
"Hey, stay on us!"
Grant snapped.
"I saw something moving back there," Derek
insisted.
"It was a rat."
Jason rolled his eyes.
"There are tons of them in here."
Derek shook his head.
"No, it wasn't a rat.
It was way too big."
"Okay, a raccoon then.
Come on, get it together.
We've been way worse locations than this.
Remember the old tuberculosis hospital?"
Grant shuddered.
"Now that was scary.
This is nothing."
"Well, not nothing."
Jason elbowed his partner.
"I did a good job scouting this place, right?"
Grant was about to answer, when his foot bumped
something on the ground.
He looked down, and saw a polaroid camera
next to a long-empty water bottle, and a small
backpack.
"Oh man, get a shot of this!"
Derek obliged, while Jason took a closer look.
"This must've belonged to one of the urban
explorer types who came in here."
He unzipped the backpack, rummaging around.
"Hey, look!
Photos, tons of them."
He dumped the pictures out onto the ground.
"Think he got some spirit photography done
before he bit the dust?"
"Might as well see..."
Grant joined Jason on the ground, sifting
through the photos as Derek watched anxiously.
"Boring, boring, deer, dog, sunset- now wait
a minute..."
He stopped, holding up one specific polaroid.
"This is the money shot right here.
Derek, zoom in on this."
All three men looked at the picture, illuminated
by the camera's light.
It showed a tall, long-limbed, pale creature,
vaguely humanoid in shape but at the same
time distinctly not quite human.
Its mouth was stretched wide in a wordless
screech, its eyes bloodshot and wild.
Its long, tapered fingers were reaching toward
the camera.
"Damn, that's spooky," Jason laughed, a bit
of nervousness creeping into his voice.
"How do you think he set this up?"
Grant asked.
"What if it's real?"
Derek swallowed the lump in his throat.
"Don't be an idiot."
Grant scoffed.
But then, from outside, not one hundred feet
away, they heard a scream.
Ear-splittingly loud, filled with rage, pain,
and animalistic instinct.
It was like nothing any of them had ever heard
before.
The scream was followed by the sound of splitting
wood, branches crashing to the ground, and,
horrifyingly, the sound of something breaking
down a nearby wall.
"What did you do?!"
Jason backed away from the sound.
"Me?!
You opened the backpack!"
Grant shot back.
"Guys???
I think we need to get out of here!"
Derek watched in wide-eyed terror as two pale
hands ripped a hole in the wall in front of
them, making an opening for that pale, hairless
head from the photograph to poke through.
All three men prepared to make a break for
it and run for their lives, but as soon as
the creature saw them, it was already too
late.
With another scream, SCP-096 sprinted toward
them, grabbing each man and throwing them
to the ground.
The camera shattered into pieces from the
impact, and Derek skidded painfully across
the ground.
As he rolled onto his side to try and push
back up to his feet, he caught a glimpse of
the monster opening its mouth impossibly wide,
and descending on his bosses.
He really didn’t want to focus on what happened
next, but suffice to say, there was nothing
of them left afterwards.
Derek tried his best to escape, but he was
no match for the brute strength and speed
of SCP-096.
From the moment he saw its face, his fate
was sealed.
There was no escape.
Soon, the beeping EMF meter, the scattered
photographs, and the broken pieces of the
camera were the only thing left of the crew
from "Ghostly Happenings."
Their devoted fans would never get another
episode.
But at least one being in the abandoned mall
could rest easy now.
SCP-096 was safe again, no one was living
who had seen its face.
It slowly crawled back to the hole it had
made in the wall, ready to return to the forest
and climb back up the mountain.
There, it could curl up beneath a tree and
stay there for as long as it wanted.
But as SCP-096 reached the hole in the wall,
where it had once been able to see night sky,
stars, and the trees in the distance, there
was only blackness.
It was as if something dark was stretched
over the opening, blocking the outside world
from view.
096 reached out a hand to push the blockage
out of the way, but whatever it was slithered
away from the touch faster than the pale hand
could move.
The wriggling darkness crept back into the
building, weaving in and out of the shadows
as SCP-096 watched it, curiously.
Whatever it was, it hadn't looked at the creature's
face yet...it wasn't sure if the thing even
had eyes.
But then, stretching out of the darkness and
into view was a garish face, wide white eyes
with massive pupils, a round nose, and a wide,
wide mouth stretched into a toothy grimace
that might have once looked like a smile.
This was the creature that had made the mall
its home, the apex predator of this biosphere,
and it was staring directly at SCP-096's face.
Its FACE!
With a shriek, SCP-096 flew into a primal
rage, clawing at the catlike creature, but
before 096 could reach it, the thing was gone.
Where was it?
Where did it go? 096 roared, tearing at the
floor, ripping up the tile and gouging long,
deep scratches in the concrete beneath.
A sound in the distance drew 096's attention,
and it bolted in the direction of the noise,
swinging at any obstacle in its path as it
went.
It ripped down a banner advertising free frozen
yogurt samples, crushed an empty cell phone
kiosk, and threw a gumball machine to the
floor with a crash.
It would rip the entire mall apart if it had
to, if that was what it took to destroy the
being that had caught a glimpse of its face
and disappeared.
Then, 096 could see it.
That face, that wide-eyed, grinning face.
It sprinted toward the face as fast as it
could.
The Cartoon Cat was looking at 096, not from
a place in the room, but from behind the screen
of a television in the electronics store window.
Somehow, defying the laws of physics and reality,
it had made its way into the tv.
SCP-096 didn't pause to ponder the logic of
this.
There was no room for critical thought.
There was only the need to shred, to consume,
to destroy.
It burst through the window, sending shards
of glass in every direction, and reared back
to attack the screen.
It was so focused on its singular task that
it didn't notice the long black arms snaking
across the floor, winding around its feet.
All of a sudden, 096 lost its balance as its
legs were pulled right out from under it,
those stretchy arms dragging it into the tv
screen itself.
When 096 regained consciousness, it was in
a place it did not recognize.
Gone was the inside of the mall, or the familiar
forest and mountains outside.
Instead, SCP-096 was in some sort of hand-drawn
world, a massive house with a hallway that
seemed to go on forever, lined with infinite
doors leading to who knew where.
The floor tipped and tilted at odd angles,
and the geometry made no three-dimensional
sense.
It was dizzying, and deeply off-putting.
SCP-096 had no frame of reference to compare
it to, but a human witness might have noticed
that this place looked like something out
of an old cartoon, from the days of Steamboat
Willy and the like.
SCP-096 did not think such a thing.
It only knew that it was in an unfamiliar
place, one that felt threatening, though there
were no visible threats.
And it knew that it still hadn't gotten its
hands on the creature that had seen its face.
All along the walls, between each door, there
were clocks in the shape of that horrible
cat, eyes ticking back and forth with each
second, wide smile mocking SCP-096, as if
to say, "try and find me."
SCP-096 would not be discouraged.
There was no room in its mind for that sort
of thing.
There was only the singular goal of finding
the Cartoon Cat and tearing it limb from rubber
hose limb.
Psychological warfare would have no effect.
Still, Cartoon Cat would give it his best
shot.
This was his world, and he could do whatever
he wanted here.
Cartoon Cat poked his head out through a random
doorway, waving to 096 with one of his puffy
white gloved hands.
As 096 wailed and began to gave chase, Cartoon
Cat slammed the door shut, only to open another
door down the hall and poke his head out of
that one.
He did the same trick over and over, jerking
SCP-096 around from end to end of the ever-expanding
animated hallway.
After some time passed, however, it appeared
SCP-096 was not going to get tired, and was
not going to give up hope of catching its
prey.
It was time to end this.
Cartoon Cat wrapped one long arm around SCP-096's
neck, restraining it against the wall, and
began to squeeze tighter and tighter.
But nothing happened.
096 did not collapse, did not react at all
except to tear at the arm around its neck
until it broke free.
Then, it returned to its relentless pursuit,
tearing doorframes apart, pulling up floorboards,
punching through walls.
Every time it dealt damage to the environment,
the space filled itself back in, an unseen
pen scribbling in the gaps in the floorboards,
sealing up the holes in the walls.
Two powerful beings going back and forth,
locked in a seemingly equally-matched battle.
Cartoon Cat tried to destroy SCP-096 in myriad
ways.
He tried to rip the beast apart, to snap its
neck, to do any manner of unspeakable violent
acts that it had done before, with great sadistic
glee.
But this pale abomination would not fold,
would not break.
This wasn't going to be any fun if there was
no ending, and if 096 kept destroying one
of Cartoon Cat's favorite pocket worlds.
That was quite enough.
Cartoon Cat grabbed hold of 096's arms and
legs, the creature thrashing viciously as
he did so, and threw it into the blank space
just beyond the illustrated world.
Back in the mall, SCP-096 crashed back to
earth.
It was about to resume its search for Cartoon
Cat, when suddenly a bright light illuminated
its face.
A police officer stood a few feet away, holding
a flashlight.
"Scuse me, you can't be in here.
You're trespassing."
The officer started to warn, but his words
were interrupted when SCP-096 began to scream.
Soon, he would be screaming too.
Now go check out “SCP-049 Cures SCP-096
of the Pestilence?!”
and “SCP-096 VS Siren Head” for more Shy
Guy crossovers you won’t be afraid to look
at!